hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
i thought i'd do a quick video on
powerline filtering um recently i did a
review of a amazon basics
amplifier you can find it on audio
science review
website and i was doing the teardown
and showing the different building
blocks and it just hit me that
most people probably don't realize that
every one of these
uh devices if it's a proper brand which
has gone through
certification regulatory certifications
for emissions and safety
already has a an ac mains filter and
quite elaborate one this owner bought
this for just 70 dollars by the way
i think it retails for 130 140 but you
see a block in here and you see a bunch
of parts in here this is the ac
mains wiring comes in here first it's
got a um
a ferrite core in here as a high
frequency filter
goes through a switch and then goes into
these components over here and
let me show you that in a on the
teardown page
you can see these components over here
these are all mains noise filter
why do they put them in there they don't
advertise them right it's not a feature
they have a switching power supply in
here and a switching power supply
basically generates these pulses with
tons of tons of energy
and that's how it gets its efficiency
but it also
generates a lot of noise that can feed
back
through the mains and go out so if you
just build this switching power supply
uh over here and don't put any filtering
on the mains wiring
it will actually send the noise over
wire and
when they start testing this for
emissions uh
both conducted and transmitted uh it
will fail
um so devices like this that have
independent
fcc certification or ce certification
by definition have uh these kinds of
noise filters in them
um the filters though don't care whether
they're
filtering noise in this direction or
from mains coming in
it's for it you know it's just parallel
on the wires
and so it effectively does tremendous
amount of filtering high frequencies not
an audible band
but then again that's exactly what
you're going to find in the uh
power strip that's uh you know it's got
filtering uh
noise filtering and these also tend to
also have protective devices like movs
and
and thermistors and others to also
handle surges
why because it costs a few cents to put
those parts in there and avoids having
to have warranty calls
uh just in case there is a surge that
comes in and damages this so
might as well just put a few cents worth
of parts in there to do this uh there's
a japan
uh standards actually uh recommendation
that uh
almost entire consumer electronics
industry follows
that mandates having such search
protection on the inputs of
of your device
another thing to note is that
a lot of times the noise inside the
device is far harder than the noise
outside and indeed that's the case over
here so
if that's the case then why worry about
the noise coming in
think about that uh if the source of
noise is in here there's
nothing you could do on the input of
this device to make it run better
because this is where all the noise is
generated not before the wire
and the argument that hey this generates
noise and it comes out and therefore you
should filter it into something
doesn't hold because again the filtering
is right here you can see that
um a while ago i did a tear down of an
unq avr
and there is also you can see this ac
filter block if you go zoom in it's kind
of a tough picture because
module was down there you can see the
capacitor in here and other parts in
here
that are designed to again clean up the
noise anytime you have
just about any kind of audio device with
any complexity to it is going to
generate internal noise anything with a
cpu
processor which these avrs have
uh against switching power supplies is
almost mandatory to put these filters in
there so all of these things will have
it
uh it was funny thing over here that
this pin wasn't soldered correctly
i wanted to move it a little bit so i'd
take a picture of it and the pin just
was up in the air so quality
control is not even good in case of some
japanese products this is a 20 year old
avr so maybe it's a you know an
exception but you can see it wasn't
properly uh
soldered but this is a 0.1 microfarad
cap it's safety rated
for its use and you can see it's got the
certifications in their csa
and so forth okay um
i have done a bunch of teardowns if you
go to uh audio video review
uh website and click on tear down
um you'll see a bunch of devices in here
and you can look inside them and and you
will find a lot of
pictures of pc boards and and you'll see
the
filters in there and it's really
standard practice
so if you feel good from having an
external filter on your device and a
surge protection on on your
in your power strip know that your
device is not naked
it has its own protection and they've
had it and that's why they're so
resilient by
the way um there they know that
ac mains is a dirty thing and some you
know it could have noise on it and
they're designed not to inject things in
it but they also try to protect
themselves as well
okay for a change we're gonna keep this
video short
see you in another one bye bye